and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Avengers
age of Ultron oh my god this is the
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
do our no strings on spoilers dears each
guys called The Avengers the sort of an
underground thing maybe you've heard of
him and they join forces again to find
Loki's long evil stick not that one foe
an Iron Man grabs this dick he gets this
terrible vision all his friends are dead
and they tell him that it was his fault
and he could have stopped it
so what does he do creates the evil
thing that's gonna destroy us all even
though he could have stopped it this
guys supposed to be a genius right so he
takes this dick increases artificial
intelligence known as Ultron and Iron
Man is like now Ultron I want you to
create peace for the world the only way
to create pieces to destroy humanity no
I promise you're programmed in that not
being an option Dule time evil now huh I
know for a smart guy I'm pretty dumb so
all truncal dr. Magneto's not kids I
like in the x-men movies where they're
not his kids either and the two whatever
like we will destroy Tony Stark that's
what I want to do as well as the rest of
the human race what nothing very well I
will not follow through on what the rest
of your plan is and assume that it will
benefit me oh it will if you like to be
dead what nothing the air-conditioning
in here so Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
why never think are called Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch go after the Avengers
and start messing with their minds like
Widow I need you to stop the Hulk from
going nuts
I can't I'm going that's too but you're
the only one who knows how to comment
down and for some reason you never
taught anybody else how to do it well
it's not like you made any more Iron Man
suits for people to wear are you for
real so Iron Man gets this super duper
mega kablooey suits which there's about
a dozen other times he probably should
use that and he uses it against the
whole the whole Matt ultra because
that's really what I want to see that
suit not in the big climax but to tell
the whole to calm down that suit and
Ultron peanut butter and jelly how did
you miss combining these two it's okay
though I get high later it's on in my
own head actually I still seeing it it
hasn't stopped yet why hasn't it stopped
yeah
we'll take a break from fighting to go
on make Hawkeye more interesting and
Quicksilver and Scarlet wit Sully decide
to switch sides we want to be on your
side well that's in Casper attic not the
sporadic as Black Widow and the Hulk
falling in love oh she just wants more
attention so she can get a toy line she
doesn't have a toy line well they said
no boy would buy a Black Widow toy maybe
because there are no black metal toys so
we just go back to pretending there's no
prejudice in the world
oh the Fox News approached bingo - iron
man clearly not learning his lesson
decide to make another artificial
intelligence in a body let's do the
logic of comic book science it seems to
work out ok I am silly looking purple
man with a cape why am I not laughing my
ass off at you you just gotta own it
like we will own Ultron ok that's why
I'm not laughing at you
also I'm stoned off my ass and you look
normal to these Ultron decides to lift a
city into the air and smash it down into
the earth like a meteorite and the
Avengers are like we must break this
island up into a million pieces which
even by this movie's logic should do
some real damage to the earth but look
more cameos from shield I'm Samuel
Jackson and I'm still awesome bye so
they finally destroy Ultron and
everybody seems to be okay except for
the whole book where are you going image
it even though I'm big green monster who
cannot think I'm suddenly thinking now
and I need time to myself no hope we
know what this really is you just want
your own movie again the other two did
so poorly I just need to know there's a
chance so why are you flying away from
me because we both know you're never
getting a movie you came and get your
own toy line goddammit it's not easy
being green shut up - looks like they're
finally adding more people to the
Avengers with none of them being
spider-man Wolverine so I don't give a
crap the end so age of Ultron was
amazing and it makes me want to create
my own superhero he's a blue man brought
to life with five magic rings that
represent all the elements I'm gonna
call him Howard the dock
this is jittery bum saying Josh God
sighs oh come on if a guy oh we have a
cannot shy come on it'll go to getting
Ghost Rider in the next movie who
doesn't want to see Nicholas Cage in the
adventures
you